well welcome back to Facebook and
uncensor we now have a little exclusive
because we are joined by the man who was
the taxi driver in this well the part of
this wild car chase with the Duke and
Duchess of Sussex uh Sunny Singh was
driving his Yellow Cab last night and
picked him up and went off for 10
minutes and then brought them back it
seems joins me now live from New York Mr
Singh thank you very much indeed for
joining me
Anova how you doing
could you tell me exactly what happened
last night
uh so I was crossing on 67th Street
going West on 67 by the precinct there
was security standing there they held me
and they said you need it are you empty
I said yes and uh like they told me to
pull aside as I pulled to the side
Prince Harry and his wife and another
lady jumped into my cab and they seemed
very nervous and uh as we went a block
we were blocked by a trash truck and
then all of a sudden Paparazzi just came
out of nowhere and just flashes just
went off how many Paparazzi would you
say there were when when you had them in
your house
six six that I seen and there were about
two cars following us uh as we as the
trash cup a trash truck moved and there
was two cars falling up and where did
they want to go
well they were just about to say the
location where they were gonna go but
then the paparazzi came and the security
guard said Hey listen just circle back
to the precinct so they had a security
guard in the cab as well
in the cab yeah okay you see him in one
of the pictures he's sitting next to me
were you surprised that they were in
your cab
uh you know not so much you know we get
celebrities in the city all the time you
know so not so much
we know that the paparazzi you don't
know who you get right you don't know
who you're gonna pick up in New York
right so right and that's true but I
mean in your experience was the
paparazzi attention any more or less
than it would be for other major
celebrities
not for them it was more it was a lot
more because I had other celebrities in
my cab as well but this one they would
because they surrounded the car and this
went crazy with the camera and how would
you just every time every yeah go ahead
how would you describe how Harry and
Megan were about this
they were nervous they were nervous
did they talk to you at all directly
ah no not as much I mean when they were
exiting they say what's your name and I
said sunny and uh that's like have a
good night and then stay exited and then
they went back into the SUV again
it's been categorized that there was a
two-hour
wild car chase through the streets of
New York but was that was the time that
must have been a
bit before me
so there was no because I think that
there was no like car chase when you
were there
um
yeah we just went
with the camera and that was it and then
and then you went back to where you'd
actually picked them up yes we went back
to the precinct and then they exited and
they thanked me and I thanked them as
well and then they exited my car did
they remember to pay you sonny
so what's your what's your view about
this you've become the most famous cab
driver in New York tonight what's your
what's your view about this inside I
don't know I don't know about that
there's another one that's on Tick Tock
if he has a bunch of celebrities in his
cat and he even got pictures with them
do you think it's uh it's been overblown
this incident or not
you know I don't know what they went
through last night right because I only
had an intersection with them for 15
minutes and they'd be very nervous while
they were in my camp
okay well Sonny listen I appreciate you
joining me the man at the center of the
of the storm quite literally I
appreciate it thank you very much uh the
pleasure talking to you too huh all the
best
okay well joining me now is the Sunday
Times columnist Charlotte Ivers the
associated to the mirror Kevin McGuire
from New York Fox News contributor and
former bodyguard to Snoop Dogg amongst
others Tyrus well Tyrus let me start
with you you're you're in New York
you've been a bodyguard to a major star
what do you make of this story
ah man you know what uh it sounds much
to do about nothing uh it you know if it
was anybody else it's just that you know
the I don't are they still the royal
family or they still don't want to be a
part of it but want to be a part of it
whatever their issue is they just come
across so thirsty all the time they
drink uh seawater but uh it sounds like
it didn't sound to me like it was that
big of a deal you're in New York it's
going to be crowded uh maybe have your
publicist stop calling Paparazzi and
tell them where you're at uh to get in a
cab to go around the corner and come
back seems silly uh when I was with
Snoop and we were approached by
Paparazzi or he was ever made to feel
nervous I would have got out of the cab
and confronted them and typically make
an example out of one guy with the
camera and the rest would follow so uh
it just seems like it was more staged
than anything else and of course a
two-hour car chase in New York uh where
were you going 15 miles an hour it's New
York you can't move so I think it's
pretty clean it wasn't too out is this
interesting no it was police a police
station at least it looks like half of
that time
sounds like South Park it's got a sequel
hahaha